in this video we'll talk about
luciferase reporter assay
luciferase reporter assay is a
bioluminescence-based assay in molecular
biology which utilizes luciferase enzyme
and its substrate luciferine to study
gene expression regulation it has wide
variety of applications like gene
expression analysis promoter strength
analysis micro rna regulation analysis
and many more
it has several advantages like it is
highly sensitive and it is reproducible
in this video we'll talk about what is
luciferase reporter assay what is the
advantage of luciferase reporter assay
applications and how the data is
analyzed and how we can account for the
variabilities and what things we should
keep in mind while analyzing the data
so stay tuned till the end of this video
and use a headphone for better quality
so let's talk about what is luciferase
luciferase is an enzyme
which give rise to bioluminescence and
it is pretty common in
fireflies
so firefly luciferase enzyme actually
converts substrates like luciferin
into
oxyluciferin luciferase enzyme actually
oxidize
luciferin and in this process light is
generated and this is the
bioluminescence phenomena this phenomena
is utilized in this particular assay as
a readout
so let's see how it works
so first we need to check whether a
particular promoter is active or not in
order to do that we have to clone a
promoter
upstream to a luciferase reporter
sequence
in this case you can see the luciferase
reporter sequence in green and promoter
sequence in red
so if this particular promoter is active
then mrna for luciferase would be
produced and eventually it would be
translated into luciferase enzyme
now when we put substrate this
luciferase enzyme will show
bioluminescence
so these expression vectors has to be
transfected into a cell
we have to allow them
for some time such that the expression
of these luciferase
enzyme can happen
and then the cells are homogenized and
then substrate is added
so once substrate is added then the
lucif the luciferase would convert
luciferin into oxy luciferin and
bioluminescence activity should be
visualized using a detector
so this is the principle which is used
in a luciferase reporter assay now let's
talk about the applications of
luciferase reporter assay there are wide
variety of applications like gene
expression analysis promoter structure
analysis and strength analysis snp
analysis it is also used in the field of
antiviral research
and therapeutics it is also used for
drug discovery and analyzing the effect
of a drug on transcription
so let's talk about some of these
examples with uh
in in much elaborated fashion so first
let's say we want to understand
whether a particular gene is expressed
in a tissue specific manner or not
so we cloned our gene of
or our promoter of interest upstream to
a luciferase reporter gene
and then we would transfect it into
different cell types
and we would check the bioluminescence
activity here the bioluminescence
activity works like a readout which
tells us whether the gene is expressed
in that particular cell type or not
in this case bioluminescence was
observed from the epithelial and
fibroblast cell not from the neuronal
cell that means
this particular gene of interest is
epithelial or neuron or fibroblast
specific and it is not expressed in the
neuron
let's take another example
we might ask whether a promoter is
strong
or weak so this is a promoter
so under the promoter there is gene body
and in the promoter rna polymerase is
recruited so when the gene is getting
transcribed we would see mrna is
produced so this particular promoter is
cloned upstream to a reporter sequence
and the reporter activity would tell us
about the strength of this promoter so
bioluminescence is a readout for
strength of the promoter
so let's take the example here we have
promoter a and here we have promoter b
in underneath both this promoter we have
the luciferase reporter gene
now we would transfect it into same cell
same number of cells as well
and then measure the luciferase activity
by putting substrates
in this very example we can see promoter
a is much stronger than promoter b
that's why bioluminescence activity is
much much stronger in promoter a
compared to promoter b
so now we understand how we can use
luciferase reporter assay to ask
questions in molecular biology we can
also understand whether a particular
protein of interest is repressing the
transcription or activating the
transcription
here this particular protein
is
possibly activating the transcription
so we have to
kind of co-transfect the cells with the
expression vector containing the protein
and also a luciferase reporter construct
if we see a lot of luciferase reporter
activity that means this particular
protein is a transcriptional activator
in contrast if the after transcription
after transfection if we see negligible
luciferase activity that means that
particular protein is a repressor of
transcription these kind of questions
can also be asked using a luciferase
reporter assay
now while performing a luciferase assay
we need to understand few precautions
so first of all there could be many
variability
that can
affect our results
for example we take less amount of cells
or there could be variability in terms
of transfection efficiency
also there could be variability during
cell handling
question is how one can account for all
these variabilities and overcome these
variabilities in their assay
question is
i mean the answer is we can use a
internal control
an internal control is kind of a
luciferase which is driven by a
constitutive promoter
and many luciferase can be used for
example rhaenyla luciferase firefly
luciferase and each of these luciferase
has their own purposes
now a normalized ratio is obtained for
each well by calculating
the experimental reporter activity
divided by the control reporter activity
so here experimental reporter means
where luciferase is driven by a
experimental promoter divided by control
reporter means
the luciferase is driven by a
constitutive active promoter
now this particular normalized ratio can
account for all the variabilities in
transfection efficiency cell number or
let's say variability in detection
now let's say we have a experiment
in this experiment we have a sample a
where we have
we want to understand the expression of
a particular gene
and in sample b we have added a drug
and we want to understand
what happens to the same gene expression
after adding this drug
so question is does drug x change change
the transcription from promoter a or not
here we are using a dual luciferase
reporter setup that means we have our
experimental luciferase vector
another is the control luciferase vector
both has to be transfected at the same
time
then obviously
from the wells we have to measure the
bioluminescence activity
and then we have to
represent the data in terms of fold
change and the fold change is actually
calculated by the normalized ratio that
we have mentioned earlier for sample b
which is a treatment situation divided
by the normalized ratio for sample a
that means the control situation and the
data can be analyzed and represented
like full change so from this data we
can understand that transcription
activity from promoter a has increased
after the exposure of drug x so these
kind of conclusions can be drawn
using these reporter assays
so let's talk about the overall
advantages it is extremely sensitive
reproducible compatible with internal
control and reporters so with these kind
of internal controls the variability is
taken care of so it is highly highly
sensitive and reproducible
and lastly this doesn't use any
radioactive substances so it is hazard
free
in summary we can say we have learned
what is reporter assay how uh reporter
assay is advantageous what are the
applications of this assay and what are
the variables that can affect our as a
result and how to overcome that
so thanks for watching if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe and
also support me on patreon or by
clicking on the super like you can
support my channel thank you